- [Thoraya] I put up a sign in public
and it got a lot of attention.
Strangers lined up to
do what the sign said
and they just kept coming
because it seemed that
the sign encouraged them
to do something that they
had already been wanting to.
So what are you here to do today?
- I'm here to let that shit go.
(interviewee laughing and clapping)
- Are there any specific instructions
or do you want me to go ahead
and start filling out the card?
- [Thoraya] The first step was to write
what they wanted to let go of.
- It feels good.
It felt like the right time and place
to think about something
I wanted to let go of
and let it go.
So it feels cathartic.
- It feels like it's, like,
off my shoulders almost.
(interviewee grunting)
- I feel kind of frustrated,
but I'm hoping that changes.
(interviewee laughing)
- It feels good, but then
also like, oh, it's silly
to be mad at something.
(interviewee laughing)
- I felt kind of like
angry while writing it.
- Doesn't serve me anymore in this life
so it's nice to write it on a paper
and kind of let it go in that aspect.
- A little strange to see
it written down on paper.
I didn't expect it to be as
impactful as it feels right now.
- It hurts
a lot.
- I feel relief that someone
else will probably read it
and I'm hoping to feel
like a whoosh of relief
once mine is tossed.
I feel calm.
- [Thoraya] Next, they had two options.
They could either get rid of
the piece of paper themselves
or they could leave it for
another stranger to read.
- I want someone else to read it.
- I'll leave it to someone else.
- And I just read it out loud?
- [Thoraya] And instruct
them on how to get rid of it.
- And then on the back it
says, "Rip up those feelings
and toss them away."
- Toss it.
- Tear this shit up please.
- Tear it up then burn it.
- Crumple it and toss.
Okay.
- Aw, this one says nurture it.
So I'm gonna go ahead and
do that, I'm gonna do that.
- I have to kiss it first
and then I have to burn it in a bonfire.
So I have to take it back
with me so I can burn it.
- Give this card a kiss and just toss it.
(lips smacking)
- [Thoraya] And once they were done,
I asked them to read a
note that another stranger
was kind enough to not only
share with them, but all of you.
- Ooh, I feel this.
- Wow, that's crazy.
It's something I really relate to.
- Oh, man.
- Okay, just read it?
- Should I read it out loud?
- This person said, "I hate my body.
I wish I could learn to appreciate
and accept that part of me,
but I am very shameful."
We gotta let that shit go.
(interviewee laughing)
- "I would like to let go
of the resentment I have
towards people who have hurt
me for no reason in the past."
(interviewee murmurs)
- "I can't talk to people I don't know.
My words get mixed up in my head
and I can't breathe normally."
(interviewee exhales)
I think a lot of people feel this way
and a lot of times, we're so
focused on our experience,
but other people are not even noticing
that we're having a hard time.
Just trying to remember
that they're not alone.
That's kind of part of
the human experience.
- "I'm trying to be more me
and less who you think I am.
I don't know why
expectations and perceptions
have so much power over me."
- "Hateful feelings."
- "My anger towards people."
- "Wanna let go of small town negativity."
- "I am still not sure that
I understand forgiveness."
I'm with them.
I'm right there with them.
I don't know if any of us
truly understand forgiveness.
I think that our understanding of that
will change as the years go on.
And as we continue to inflict pain
onto other people and
experience it ourselves.
I think it'll continue to change.
Definition of forgiveness right now?
(interviewee exhaling)
Being able to not necessarily empathize
with what someone has done to you,
but sympathize with
what they've done to you
and accept it instead of actually
understanding how or why,
accepting that they did.
- I'm not ready to let go of anything yet
because I'm still learning from it.
And I'll release it
when I'm done learning.
- Ooh, I feel this.
It says, "Procrastination.
I haven't done my taxes."
I gotta do mine, too, I feel that.
- "The pressure of being expected
to be immediately successful
as a young adult."
Woo, I understand that.
I am not really a young adult,
but I understand self-imposed
pressure to be successful.
- "Grief that piles up and
makes me feel too heavy
to be confident.
Self-doubt."
- "My obsession of being normal."
- "Refusing to take care of myself."
- "I have been sensitive
for way too long."
Well, this person who wrote
this is working on it.
And I would say to keep going
and keep talking about it
and keep working on it and
explore it a little bit more.
- "I found so much freedom and power
in realizing that I don't have to."
I really like this one
(interviewee laughing)
because it kind of matches what I wrote
and it makes me feel
better after what I wrote.
- "I still check what music she listens to
and wonder if her playlists are about me."
- "My feelings for my ex."
- "I can't forget about my
ex who treated me horribly.
She's moved on, but I still love her
and I want to let it go.
It's been eight months
and she's the only girl I've ever loved."
I had a feeling I would
get something like this.
(interviewee laughing)
- "The anger I still have towards my ex."
I guess he broke her heart.
So, but they ain't telling
me to do nothin' with it,
so I guess they want me to go find them.
(interviewee laughing)
You just can't just give
somebody your heart like that.
I mean, you should just,
like, slice his tires
or something like that cause
I like 'em crazy, you dig?
(interviewee laughing)
I want my girl to slice my tires.
- "Longing for someone I've never met."
- "The constant desire to meet my person."
I kind of love that 'cause I feel like
there's so much pressure nowadays
to, like, meet the right person.
Like, that you have a soulmate out there
that you, like, are gonna
meet at the right place
at the right time.
And so you're always, like, stressed about
when that's gonna be and
like how to set yourself up
for that and so I think it's
awesome to, like, let that go
and just be yourself and
that person will come to you
eventually if there is
that kind of person.
- Wow, that's crazy.
It's something I really relate to.
"Feeling confused about if
my mother was there for me
the way I needed her to be
and loving her so much still."
And it said, "I want you to burn this."
So I will burn this for them
as a good community member.
- They said, "My mom."
- This person put, "I really want kids,
but I'll never admit it
as I think I'd turn out like my mom."
I feel that
- I wrote, "Disappointment
and expectations
from my parents."
Can I read one?
Having to leave my parents to
chase different opportunities.
Whoa, that's kind of weird.
Ours were kind of like the opposite.
That's so weird.
Okay, I didn't like it.
- So I wrote "Anger,
resentment, and frustration
towards my father."
He wasn't very kind in my childhood.
And he's gotten better,
he's gotten better.
But it's still not a hundred
percent and that hurts.
But let's see somebody else's shit
that we're about to let out.
Let's see.
Ah, see, like, same shit, same shit.
"The amount of guilt I
feel when thinking about
how critical I've been to my parents."
No, yeah, I totally agree.
I think that like when
things get heated, you know,
people say things that
they don't really mean
and it's not a good, like, family dynamic.
Then you grow up and you learn
all these, like, bad lessons
on, like, how you should treat people
and, like, the feelings you
have towards other people
and, like, what they did.
At the end of the day, no
one's perfect, you know?
And it's not healthy for
you to be holding out
all that bad negative energy.
It's just, you know,
like, you only live once.
So, like, why spend it
miserably, you know?
It's just no point.
- "Expectations placed on me
by my religious community.
I want to express myself and be me
rather than be what I am expected to be."
- This one says, "Negative
feelings towards myself."
Something we all struggle with
that we all are here
to learn and overcome.
- "I am so mad at (no audio)
for not responding to my
email and text message.
She at least should be
considerate of my time."
- "I want to get rid of being
unemployed and video games
so that I can care for
my wife in a deep way."
- "I navigate the world
as if every word I say
can be used against me.
I'm not even sure who I
am, so mistrusting of."
I can most definitely relate to it.
It's essentially similar
to what I wrote myself.
- And then this one says,
"I've never told anyone this,
because I don't like upsetting anyone
from how morbid it sounds.
But I think about s****de every day.
It's exhausting and I just
wish it felt more comfortable
talking about it."
Well, I hope that person is listening
and I hope that they are more
comfortable speaking about it
and they don't think about that any longer
because, I mean, they don't
deserve to feel that way.
So I'm really hoping
that they let that go.
And they said, "Give this
card a kiss and just toss it."
Okay.
(lips smacking)
(gentle music)